growing international concern this hour
over a new coronavirus variant that
scientists say could be more infectious
than previous strains the world health
organization has assigned it the greek
letter omicron and labeled it as the
fifth variant of concern omicron was
first detected by researchers in south
africa and many countries are now
imposing travel bans to stop its spread
there's a dreadful feeling we've been
here before as the last flights from
southern africa arrive at airports in
london and paris on friday
the eu agreed on the need to temporarily
halt travel to the region after
commission president ursula van der lion
called for unity from the block
we're taking the news about the new
highly mutated covet 19 variant very
seriously
we do know that mutations could lead to
the emergence and spread of even more
concerning variants of the virus
that could spread worldwide within a few
months
it is now important that all of us in
europe act very swiftly
decisively and united
but the world health organization has
warned against countries hastily
imposing travel restrictions on south
africa and neighbouring countries who
recommends
that countries continue to apply a
risk-based and a scientific approach
when implementing travel measures
in accordance with the temporary
recommendations of the ninth emergency
committee
the first case of the new kovig-19
variant in europe has been found in
belgium with confirmed cases in hong
kong botswana and israel
the omnicron variant named after the
greek letter was first detected in
haoteng south africa's most populous
province
and it's feared it could be more
transmissible and vaccine resistant
the impact of travel restrictions on an
already struggling economy are also a
concern for locals
it's bad because we suffer for three
years without business and now the
variances are gonna kill us how can we
survive so the cancellation of flight
is going to affect us big time because
there will be no tourism at all and our
business really lies
on tourism
as passengers rushed to leave south
africa experts are warning that the new
variant will almost certainly reach more
countries
uw correspondent adrian kriesch is in
south africa and sent us this reaction
from cape town
the past few weeks here in cape town
almost felt too good to be true with low
infection rates life slowly got back to
normal for the first time since the
beginning of the pandemic
tourists from around the world filled up
the city once again now the new variant
was discovered and it brings back a deja
vu of sorts to what has happened about
one year ago back then south african
scientists discovered the beta variant
here and while the detection here does
not mean that it originated from south
africa
same case for the current variant by the
way it had devastating impacts on the
economy of the country there were lots
of travel restrictions imposed on south
africans who were not allowed to travel
to many countries abroad but this also
reduced the number of tourist arrivals
here in south africa a scenario that we
are likely to see again now at a time
when summer the major tourist season has
just started that would have brought
much needed boost to the tourism
industry the pandemic has made the
massive unemployment and poverty crisis
in south africa even worse and once
again no end in sight
let's bring in wolfgang prizer he's the
head of the division of medical virology
at stellenbosch university and he joins
me from cape town mr preiser welcome to
the program the who is now calling this
variant one of concern what does that
mean exactly
it means that it has properties that um
yeah that that are of of concern and
that could be that either it it
can evade the immune response it can
infect infect
vaccinated individuals or it causes more
severe disease or it is more easily
transmissible or any combination of the
above and unfortunately wh o
has come to the right conclusion this
variant at least from the genetic
properties that it has looks as if it
could do a few of those tricks
um so it's something we really need to
worry about and something we need to
investigate
very quickly
you mentioned vaccines and the potential
that this variant has to evade the
vaccines we now have this life-saving
medicine
vaccine inequality across the globe this
is a real issue would we be in this
situation if wealthier nations had done
a better job of sharing this life-saving
medicine
i speak under correction because there
are many aspects of this new variant
that we don't know yet for example where
it originated we found it here in south
africa it was also found in neighboring
botswana and then in travelers that had
come back from south africa so we think
it may have arisen in the south african
region we don't know exactly where i'm
saying that because south africa is in
the unique situation of among african
nations of actually having currently
enough vaccines for the eligible
population
the problem that we are facing is
vaccine hesitancy it's very much unlike
the industrialized countries where
there's more vaccine than there are
willing takers other african countries
of course are not in the same fortunate
position they do not have enough
vaccines so i'm not diminishing that
argument at all but should that
variant have arisen here in south africa
it could not be blamed on not having
enough vaccine it would rather have to
be blamed on
the vaccination program
population hesitancy
and resistance to to vaccination
mr preiser it was south african
researchers who detected it and they
sounded the alarm very quickly to the
rest of the world and some countries now
have placed a travel ban on that part of
the world is that the right decision do
travel bans actually work
well yes and no i i must say i have
sympathy with these decisions it seems
like the obvious thing you don't want
this to be
introduced to your own country so you
you prevent people from entering and and
if they do enter then then they have to
go and current time and so on
in the long run it won't keep it at bay
so i think it's an immediate measure i
just wish that south africa is not once
again like already last year when we
also identified the better variant is
not
sort of punished if you want by being
placed under travel restrictions
long after the the actual risk has
weighed so my my expectation is that
this time around and these travel bans
and other measures will be revisited
quickly and regularly as new evidence
emerges and we are busy working on that
we have the borrowers in the lab we are
setting up epidemiological studies and i
think that within weeks from now we will
know a lot more about it and can decide
just how concerning it really is is it
such a problem as we fear it might be or
maybe after all it is not quite as bad
so let us hope for for the latter and
let us hope that if it doesn't turn out
to be quite as bad as as people may fear
that then also these restrictions are
lifted and i think the ultimate message
of course must remain that our best bet
to get out of this pandemic situation is
universal vaccination so we we cannot
really be safe until everyone on earth
is vaccinated and thereby protected
against at least severe disease and
death because this virus doesn't see
borders virologist wolfgang prizer at
stellenbosch university thank you very
much for your time
we're going to stick with the story and
bring in steven beardsley who's with dw
business he joins me now in studio
stephen let's talk about the financial
world how is it reacting to the news of
this new variant
we're seeing a lot of sell-offs right
now from global markets uh wall street
for example the biggest capital markets
out there we're seeing two percent
losses from each of the major indexes
dow jones s p 500 that's pretty big what
we're seeing is a lot of deja vu from
the first days of the pandemic around
two years ago
where investors they don't have a clear
view on things than we do but they feel
like they know where things could go
we're seeing it with the travel
restrictions and with the possibility of
lockdowns what that means is that if
there's less traveled and there's less
need for
say oil for example oil prices are
falling lockdowns would also pull back
on travel
we're also seeing that
that shares in companies that for
example are researching medicines that
are researching vaccines those are
rising and we're seeing investors try
and move their money into safer places
they're moving into things like u.s
treasuries and out of cryptocurrencies
so we're seeing a lot of movements of
investors trying to get their money into
a safer place because they're saying in
the worst case scenario this could look
like it did two years ago it's important
to remember here that many businesses
have not fully recovered from the first
wave
we're just degunking supply chains still
they're not there yet and so this could
further throw that into issue many
companies are still looking for workers
consumer behavior has changed over the
last few years so
there's a lot of complication when you
look at
you know where businesses stand as they
just start to imagine the possibility of
a new another round of a pandemic
certainly economies around the globe
have been hard hit as you mentioned some
are still struggling to recover what
kind of further setback could this new
variant now potentially have i mean it
could be pretty substantial because we
haven't seen economies fully recover
we've seen that 2022 2023 many economies
were supposed to
come closer in that direction it depends
on whether they were advanced economies
like germany like the united states
developing economies for example in
africa they were going to need longer
this could set them back even further
you know in the meantime to get there
many countries have taken on a lot of
debt and while countries like germany
and the u.s can afford that debt people
will buy it in africa they can't afford
it and also elsewhere here in the eu if
you look at the debt loads on italy for
example this could put new strains on
many countries as they try and bridge
that gap to the end of the pandemic
wherever that is or whatever that is
you know what we're also going to see
here is some fundamental questions about
globalization and the ideas behind it if
this is as bad as many people are making
it out to be that means the idea that
countries really rely on each other to
follow their strengths to trade with one
another
and to not create redundancies in the
system but if everyone says we're going
to have to close borders down we can't
rely on supply chains working then there
are big issues about
what we're going to do in the future
there's also the issue of inequality and
that's going to be a growing concern as
well many african nations again many
lower income nations we realize that
black the black economy black black uh
the black economy is really important
for these workers that tends to suffer
first when things like tourism fall and
tourism hasn't returned to many of these
countries look at bali look at south
africa they're still waiting on those
people to return and so if many of the
workers who serve them
in that economy if they're not able to
come back then that means less wages for
them that means less economic well-being
so in the end this is all about jobs and
livelihoods including what we're seeing
with wall street that's really what it
comes down to is these companies their
ability to stay on their feet and
provide jobs and livelihoods for people
dw businesses stephen beardsley thanks
for walking us through that stephen